ladies and gentlemen we're coming to you
from the world famous button club
i'm here with the proprietor joel maizel
otherwise known as michael ziegan can i
tell you a secret sure you're my first
ah
first what you're my first interview oh
is that right yeah so you will always be
my first
i i don't know what to say about that
let's pop some cherries and get this
going
[Music]
now you've done a lot of theater and
you've done a lot of film and television
you've done it all
now in this show in mazel which is such
a gift
you know amy sherman palladino
developing this world for people
is so crucial and important and it's
obviously really connected with people
you know i bet you get a little of that
tingle when you do those big wanna shots
because that's like a cross between
theater and film yes absolutely talk to
me about the warners because for any
performer out there it's like stand up
it's like theater you know there's a lot
on the line
you can't screw it up because you'll
sabotage it for everyone else what do
you say to yourself i i just i see it as
a challenge and i'm i'm up for it i to
me they're the most fun
um high stakes yeah high stakes you
don't want to mess up but if you do it's
okay you can go back to the beginning
have you ever messed up of course what
do you say to everyone oh i'm so sorry
oops yeah
and everybody understands because we all
mess up at some point
but yeah we just they probably want to
kill you but they get it it's possible
yeah yeah um they don't want to be on
the other end of it either though but
it's so funny when it's not you you
judge and when it's you you're like oh
god
but we did we just did a a big warner
for this last episode that we filmed and
um
typically we don't even know that we're
we're going to be doing a oner you know
it was four different scenes it was it
was four scenes and then we show up and
amy decided we're gonna just
mesh them all together and um
and you know so it's like you come down
a hallway you walk into a room you do a
scene in the room then you come out of
the room do a scene in the hallway and
um it's nerve-wracking but that's what
makes it so much fun you see it you feel
the energy you feel the intensity of
like something's happening here and i'm
in the middle of a live act right you
know
and listen editing is an art too don't
get me wrong sure they're both valid but
i love you know the baseball scene that
got a lot of recognition and these risks
that you guys take because you got to
work together as a team the baseball
scene was another one where we didn't
know coming into it that it was going to
be all in one shot and it actually was
was a little longer they they cut some
of it off the end but i mean
you know and we have to hit
every baseball that you know we throw up
so
um
so that was tough and it definitely
didn't happen in one take you know it it
was take after take after take but you
get that feeling after a take right
totally you're like that's the one yeah
i hope they use that one yeah sort of
like usually the last one
well like yeah because they're like
let's move on one thing i really want to
talk to you about that i love about the
show
is that a woman created it
you know with her husband
and it's about
a marriage a couple
yeah maybe they're divorced but let's
face it once you have kids
you're never divorced what a ridiculous
word divorced right
there should be a new term for it like
we're not stooping
but we still have the kids so we're
going to co-parent like everything's
great for them and we're going to work
our stuff out on the sidelines and might
from time to time well you know i guess
once one such stopper always a stripper
very wise words what i love about
life
is that
because of the kids you kind of keep
working on it you know if you don't if
you don't have kids you just bail on
each other and move on and oh that
didn't work out boohoo and you live your
separate lives but when you have kids
you're forced to be together you're
forced to like
have to
grow
and i think you guys have grown so much
why do you think you guys have nailed it
so perfectly
um i think just because of the writing
cause
you know amy sherman palladino and dan
palladino are so talented and it's not
like they would know anything about that
they don't have kids and they're happily
married
but they're just so talented and
yeah it is tough i mean you know
joel
his ex-wife midge is living out his
dream
so he he kind of has to deal with that
but uh also find a new dream and
um
and i i do feel like they've really
nailed it i i think it's it definitely
feels real and uh authentic
i mean if i could have a nickel for all
the guys that came through the club and
you know wanted to stop and yet they
couldn't handle the fact that i was
running the show
you know
you like it one minute and then you want
to take it down the next and
think about your own insecurities it's
like come on you know aren't we here to
all build each other up
and you know i think the uh man woman
dynamic that plays out in this show is
very
very rich
because comedy and no comedy
men and women
they fall in love with things they grow
they change and they gotta deal with all
the insecurities and complexities that
come with that only to realize maybe one
day they could actually support each
other appreciate each other and then
expand on that
sure do you think that's what you guys
are doing in the show it seems like that
as a viewer so far
yeah um people always ask me like you
know are joel and midge gonna end up
together yeah that's the question
everybody asked yeah do they just want
them to get back together right and
there's some competition you know uh
zachary levi played a character that
everybody loved and lenny bruce you know
luke kirby plays lenny bruce you got the
milo yes yeah they got a gentleman
coming down the pike who's an old amy
sherman paladino
right but still they want this joel
image and
um
i don't know you know i i have no idea
well i think history and chemistry
are not to be underrated
but what's really not to be underrated
is how you grow in this world together
and sometimes you grow apart and you
come back together or you grow alongside
of each other but no one can replace
when you really know somebody
right
doesn't matter that history it really
can't be contended with so i love
watching you guys
thank you mitzi
you're welcome
and you're easy on the eyes toots
now
you started the club are you liking it
how do you like what are you looking for
when you see talent what's one thing
that you think oh god get the hook get
them off
or one thing where you're like
[Music]
i mean talent is talent isn't it you
know it when you see it
um
you're talking about joel or
like yeah joe
when joel sees you know
he's living out his own dream he wants
to be a comedian yeah but you know but
he wasn't funny funny yeah he was taking
other people's material well they get no
you shouldn't steal stealing is wrong
yeah
the karma will come
but now you have now he has this club
what is you know the ultimate goal with
the club is it to
shine lights on other people or is it to
have a safe haven to go when all this
[ __ ] is happening in the world and
somewhere to forget about it
um
i think for joel it's it's
it's it's that but it's also
just to have a purpose you know
um i think he was lost before i think
like i said he tried doing stand-up that
wasn't for him he worked at a plastics
company that clearly wasn't for him but
i think i think he's he's creative i do
i think he he needs to be in something
that uh
that is creative and and this is this is
a great outlet for him and you know he
also likes the business uh business
aspect of it
and uh so i think his ultimate goal is
just
to have a purpose and to be successful
in that purpose i gotta tell you zegan
and i don't give up compliments very
easily
you got the goods
you really do i mean it i've been a long
time fan
of yours i always thought you had the
goods you're handsome you're funny if
men only knew that the secret to a woman
is making her laugh
[Music]
you